big day almost here for some ccsd
students after nearly a year of distance
education
some of the youngest kids heading back
to the classroom next week
orco mana joining us live with the
timeline and the plea
from older students tonight that would
still be on a screen
orca yeah brian hybrid learning for
pre-k
through third grade students starts on
monday but for middle and high school
students
their transition won't start until late
march and early april
and for some that's not fast enough
it's been very hard for us it's been a
whirlwind of a year for ccsd students
they've dealt with a lot from distance
learning challenges to mental health
struggles but now there's a light at the
end of the tunnel
with extra sanitation and social
distancing protocols in place ccsd
campuses
are reopening their doors some pre-k to
third graders start face-to-face
instruction on monday as part of the
hybrid model
other grade levels will stagger that
transition beginning on either march
22nd
or april 6th but many older students say
they want to be back in the classroom
now and they're urging district leaders
to take action
they should step up and tell their
school members and their trustees and
their superintendents to step
up and let's get this done and get back
into in-person learning i understand
their concerns
but ccsd superintendent dr jesus dara
still says this is the best path forward
i'd rather go slow and steady and
carefully before we go too fast and then
have to close our school so that's the
plan that we have in place i think it's
a
doable plan but for high school seniors
they say their futures are at stake
time is like running out but if we can
just go back full time to school
i can figure out what my life's going to
look like
now it's important to note that ccsd
will still offer
full-time distance education for
families who prefer that
and by the way april 6th this date right
here is when pre-k through fifth grade
students
are set to return to the classroom five
days a week
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now